all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are continuing to get caught
up on all the dawn of x
stuff so we can kind of continue our
coverage of rain of x i'll specify in
the videos like in this video for
example this takes place before the
events of x of swords right so we'll
make sure it's in the playlist
adequately and if you guys want to get
caught up on our x-men stuff and the
upload schedule's kind of confusing you
a bit make sure you guys check out the
playlist down in the description that
has all the x-men stuff in chronological
order but just so you guys know
marvel started the x-men with dawn of x
then they went into x of swords or ten
of swords and now we're in
reign of x and that's where all that
kind of stuff is going on so again it's
a little bit hectic i'm trying to get
caught up and trying to organize it as
best i can because they're just
releasing so much stuff
it's it's kind of nuts but in the the
first video that we did because
technically we did part one
of wolverine and all that really
centered around were a couple different
people one was jeff bannister
then his daughter who was basically
dying of cancer and then something
called the flower cartel
and all we knew is that the flower
cartel was basically taking the
flowers of cocoa that were capable of
healing different things like that and
they were essentially
adjusting them and then selling them off
right and the whole point was to
basically make money and we've seen that
before right we've seen that in
different ways people taking the
medicines of cocoa and then repackaging
them and then setting them off in
different ways and making their own
money and that kind of thing
largely to people who live in countries
where the government refuses to
recognize krakowa and so as a result
they won't get any of those medicines
and different things like that so
the result of this is that wolverine was
basically tasked with tracking down the
flower cartel
and ultimately figuring out what was
going on now the first thing we had
really in the last video is you had what
was called the pale girl basically this
girl that seemed to work with the flower
cartel that could actually cast
illusions
in people's minds and seemingly take
over them and what it did is it actually
led wolverine into a bit of a scuffle
where it seemed like he was going crazy
and then ultimately rescued by jeff
bannister which really kind of leads us
here the big thing about this is that
for most mutants in krakowa
they don't trust people from the human
race right they don't trust average
humans but wolverine's been around the
block enough times to know that there
are humans out there you can trust
and even if you can't necessarily trust
them there are humans that you need and
jeff bannister
is one of the good guys and so
essentially working alongside bannister
who is a cia agent the two of them kind
of start going through and trying to
figure out what's going on with the
flower cartel find its location
where it is they're doing meetups
different things along those lines and
then the middle of it all
wolverine snaps and kills jeff bannis or
at least stabs jeff bannister and i
wouldn't go as far as to say jeff's dead
but ultimately jeff bannister is more or
less out of commission here and the
reason why
is because the pale girl has basically
arrived and taken over the mind of
wolverine and so what this does
is it leads to kind of jumping back to
the day before
and you kind of have this bit of a
conversation between wolverine and
magneto and the cool thing about this
is wolverine one of the things he says
is that given his life experience and
the various things that he's done
that he came to this realization pretty
early on that because of his healing
factor because of his adamantium because
of the fact that
in a lot of ways his past is a little
checkered which is kind of an
interesting thing
kind of an aside here one of the things
that benjamin percy talks about when
he's writing wolverine and one of the
things that wolverine mentions is he
doesn't fully remember his past
that's something that's that's kind of a
return to familiarity because
if you guys recall following house of m
one of the things that happened is
wolverine remembered his whole history
and so it seems like being reborn again
or being brought back kind of resets him
back to the version of himself where he
doesn't know his full history
it's kind of interesting a little bit
murky we'll probably have to just kind
of wait and see how things unfold to
know whether that's actually the case or
not but basically wolverine
spikes the drink of magneto now he does
this in front of frank dukes also known
as as the blob
this is a big thing and the reason why
is because when it comes to the ruling
government of krakowa
charles xavier magneto the other members
of the quiet council they're largely
hands off right mutants do
not go after them or sabotage them or
knock them out or in any real form or
fashion show a manner of disrespect
because what that does is it
undermines the government and if people
don't believe in the government they
won't believe in gracoa and so they
would basically lead to the collapse
of the mutant population or at least the
mutant haven as it exists in krakowa but
for wolverine himself what he does is he
actually steals the helmet of magneto
and the reason why is because
he's got a plan that when everything
kind of pops off in this current moment
and he ends up basically
at least looking like he takes out jeff
bannister and the pale girl makes her
appearance that is all part of the plan
that wolverine has for himself
the other follow-up thing he'd done
after meeting with magneto is he had
actually gotten with quentin choir now
the conversation between quentin choir
and wolverine is kind of a funny thing
because if you guys recall the x-men in
the mid-2000s
one of the things that quentin choir had
done was actually use the drug kick to
enhance his telepathic abilities and
then basically took over the entirety of
the xavier school right literally led a
revolt against the teachers and it was
pretty amazing
there's a little bit of history here and
so right off the bat wolverine knows
that quentin choir is not going to be
interested in working with him and
that's when you get these stepford
cocoons right the
the young girls who are basically clones
of emma frost they call them the five
and one is another name they refer to
them as but they're one of these groups
where basically when they work in unison
their telepathy is exceedingly powerful
they do have it individually but they
work better when they're they're kind of
uh working as a hive mind right so
as the five and one they're greater than
the sum of their parts is essentially
what it means but
basically the direction of wolverine
they just spend a whole lot of time
flirting with quentin choir like damn
man we heard you were gonna go after the
p.o girl quentin that's so
sexy that's so hot quentin's like yeah
man the funny thing about that is in
order for this deal to be made and in
order for it to all go down
it's because wolverine basically agreed
to set up the stepford cacoos with the
guy they actually want who's basically
cable
they want to get with cable but the
reason why wolverine did this stealing
the helmet of magneto working with
quentin choir is because he needs this
whole group to operate at their full
capacity in order to take out the flower
cartel that the pale girl
is strong enough in and of herself but
one of the things that's gone on here
is that it's the russian government that
what had happened is the russian
government's kind of considered to be an
exiled nation
because they're a non-treaty nation
seemingly it can go a couple different
ways either we can believe in the most
ridiculous possibility which is that the
russians have no treaties with anybody
or wolverines just using that term in
relation to krakowa that they're a
non-treaty nation with cricoid therefore
they're kind of exiled away from kakoa
but the whole the whole point behind
this is that what they've been doing
is basically snatching up flower petals
that are coming from kokoa and then in
doing that
kind of repurposing them and then
selling them off and so to do this in
order to ensure they can kind of operate
behind the scenes with seemingly nobody
aware of what they're doing what they've
done is built their own sort of man-made
island right literally
like a giant you know submersible is
really what it is it's not really a
submarine but it's not really a ship
it's kind of this weird blend between
the two but basically it seems like it
operates in russian waters so they don't
really have to worry about any kind of
uh
treaty violations against other
countries i guess they could do it in
international waters but doing it in the
waters of russia basically means
no one can really do anything to them
without potentially sparking a conflict
with russia
and so because of that the the flower
petals are kind of brought back there
and they do their thing but wolverine
kind of shows up here with with iceman
and with storm and with bishop and then
with uh with pyro and more or less kind
of executes this mission right the
biggest problem they have
when they run into the pale girl is the
pale girl seemingly takes takes over
some of the other x-men or at least
takes over jeff bannister who's actually
kind of recovering and is actually alive
the whole point behind this is that
because wolverine kind of cares about
jeff bannister
and because there's a lot of history
there that ultimately he kind of backs
off a little bit lets the pale girl go
and then basically saves jeff banister
this is kind of a way for benjamin percy
to sort of give us this idea that the
pale girl is going to come back
the reality is we don't really know much
about her we don't really have a lot of
history there
the only thing that we have and i don't
know if it's really even a clue so much
as just the illusion that was being cast
in the mind of jeff bannister as he
refers to the girl as his daughter we
don't actually know if that's the case
and wolverine goes as far as to say
that's not your daughter that's the pale
girl it could very well be that it
is we're not entirely sure one of the
things that goes on here is wolverine
actually gets this girl
put on the they're really taken off the
waitlist for medicine that can cure her
and then basically gives her the kind of
meds that can you know take away our
cancer kind of the power of cocoa but
it's basically sort of doing a favor for
jeff bannister right like you saved my
life now i'm gonna save the life of the
thing the most valuable to you which is
the life of your daughter
kind of a cool little bit of a of a
favor there not only that there's
actually a little curcumin gate that's
left behind there meaning of course
jeff bannister is going to be one of
these almost sort of senator robert
kelly type guys from marvel comics back
in the 70s and 80s where basically he's
an ally to the x-men and he's in a
pretty powerful position not the most
powerful but in a relatively powerful
position
the problem is that were the days more
or less saved here on behalf of
wolverine
suddenly krakow is met by the arrival of
omega red and omega red kind of says
like i understand that you guys are
offering amnesty now as soon as he
appears
wolverine's right on this guy right for
a couple different reasons one
because anybody who knows anything about
marvel comics will tell you that ever
since omega red's debut and x-men volume
2
issue number four like him and wolverine
have just been fighting and even before
that there's a lot of history like
despite that being his first appearance
marvel came back and said there's
actually a lot of history between these
guys and they've been fighting each
other for a long long time
and that are katy rosavich was like a
murderer before he became omega red that
he's got a really dark and shady history
and wolverine's been tracking him around
for years now the reality is
when it comes to arcadia and this is one
of the things we talked about in our
video on omega red explained
the only thing he really cares about is
finding the carbonation synthesizer
which will basically stabilize the
carbonadium in his body which is quite
literally eating him alive
and once it's stabilized he'll be fine
right he'll kind of be able to be his
normal
self the the idea here seems to be that
he needs the carbonation synthesizer he
has to use it on a regular basis
in order to keep his body in check and
that's usually how people end up using
omega red they're like hey i have a
carbanium synthesizer but if you want it
you got to go kill this guy here right
that's usually how it works well this
character has kind of been a mainstay
ever since the 1990s
but ultimately magneto steps in pulls
wolverine off and says understand
here on kokoa there are no good guys and
bad guys right it's simply just mutants
as a whole and
unless they commit a crime against the
mutant population or possibly a crime
against humanity that's done
in such a way to where it presents a
credible threat to gracoa
they're hands off you leave him alone if
he came here and said he's looking for
amnesty you have to let him have that
and so ultimately he's just kind of like
if you really want to find out what's
going on here if you want to know
why it is that omega red's covered in
blood then some of it might be a lot of
his own whatever the case is
your job is to go find out what's going
on with him right to find out where he
came from and why it is he's covered in
blood and that kind of thing right as a
member of x-force that's kind of your
job and so wolverines kind of sent
through the portal of kokoa basically
back through where omega red came from
only to arrive in paris france and when
he gets there he basically finds a truck
or at least a car
and his trunk is full of bodies which is
really kind of messed up and sort of
screwed up
but as wolverine kind of starts touring
around and almost kind of investigating
you know is omega red really telling the
truth when he says he's here because he
really is seeking amnesty because he's
looking to turn over a new leaf and
looking to become a good guy or is there
some kind of ruse here did omega red
come here because
somebody sent him here right is he
basically designed to be a mole or
somebody designed to extract the other
members of the x-men and then
dupe them into you know basically being
killed and so as he kind of follows
around
and sort of follows this trail he
actually ends up coming across a woman
bearing flowers
the funny thing is we don't really know
anything about her instead he kind of
descends down or at least is kind of led
down into this little bit of a
of an underground club almost something
akin to a speak easy and then he
consumes a drink and then passes out and
when he wakes up
he's strung up come to find out he's in
the layer of vampires and the funny
thing about this is that the vampires
who are here are actually seeking to
drink the blood of wolverine
for a couple different reasons the first
is because they're vampires and they
drink blood but two
the hope is that the blood of wolverine
would actually allow them to
to really benefit from this healing
factor and then heal from being able to
be in the sun
because while vampires do have a healing
factor it's kind of this inevitable
aspect of them as vampires that they
can't exist in the sun right it's one of
those things that marvel sort of
consolidates and they say their healing
factor
doesn't quite work on that and if it
does it doesn't work fast enough
right that basically it's it's the
amount of time it takes for them to die
from sunlight far
outstrips the speed of their healing
factor and so because of that
you know the hope is that they can use
wolverine's blood to basically heal
themselves or at least to be able to
walk around in the sun now of course
wolverine breaks free as you would
expect luis shows up with a uv hand
cannon only to reveal that she's part of
a group called the night guard now this
is a really important
thing because in marvel comics for a
long long time all you really had here
were a couple things going on the first
is that you had blade who hunted
vampires and two you would have like the
midnight sons who might come into
contact with him but the night guard is
kind of this
compliment to the idea of blade not in
so far as louise basically says yeah
like i'm friends with blade we hang out
all the time
it's not really something like that it's
one of those things where it's kind of
like blade's not the only one that
fights vampires that there are actual
orders out there that exist
that try to destroy the vampire threat
as best they can the funny thing about
this
is that when luis brings all this
information to his attention
what she says is you'd have to be some
kind of fool to believe that humanity
are the only ones who are vying to bring
down the mutant population
while the vampires are looking to do
that the reality is they see this as a
chance to
basically launch their own campaign but
the reality of what's going on
is you as mutants have drawn the
attention of the human world everybody's
focused on you and if they're focused on
you they're not focused on anybody else
so vampires are using this as a chance
to essentially consolidate their their
numbers behind the scenes and that these
guys that you're facing off against
right these these enemies who are there
the reality is they're not the main
force right the main enemy they have
is basically vlad dracula you know that
mutants have charles xavier you guys are
all united and that's great that
humanity has its governments and united
is
in whatever form you want to call it
command doesn't really have like a
singular leader it's just a whole bunch
of different
nations that are all just kind of
bickering amongst each other but
ultimately
humanity is really in a position to
where they could fail here that either
mutants or vampires will likely win now
of course this also brings into question
the idea of like post-humans those the
the children of the vault but not really
anybody knows about that right it's kind
of this this small and hidden thing
and so ultimately this is all kind of
brought to the attention of the quiet
council where wolverine's like you guys
need to be aware that this is something
that's actually going on here the quiet
council does recognize it but the quiet
counselor kind of tasks him with again
figuring it out and getting a more
in-depth analysis of what's actually
happening here and so what wolverine
does is he actually ends up taking a
kind of
personal or really a private portal that
he has for himself to a place of the
north up in canada because it's
basically one of these places that he
goes to for this personal solace and
retreat the problem is that when he gets
into this bar he's immediately attacked
and the reason why is because for years
and years and years while this bar had
been a safe haven the reality is
there are people here now that have a
vendetta against him that have a grudge
with him not only that like once he
actually goes to use the restroom and
then he comes back like
there's this realization that somebody
in the bathroom had basically been
killed that like somebody there was
essentially destroyed and the question
was who was it that did it but who was
it that caused this and that's one of
the things when he realizes it's
basically the brotherhood militia right
like oregon years ago that kind of a
thing there's a lot of history there so
when wolverine's knocked out what we end
up finding out is the people who are
here
know that this is a bar that wolverine
frequents and when he first showed up
here
it kind of blew their minds but the
reality is they've all lost somebody
close to them
because of wolverine and so one of the
things that happens for example is that
with one of these guys there was a fight
in madrapore that happened some number
of years ago and wolverine was in the
center of it this guy's fiance was hit
in the head with a chair which cracked
her skull
and then a blood clot killed her a week
later it's one of these things where
it's kind of wolverine's ghost of the
past that are coming back to visit him
the problem with this is they realize
you cannot simply kill wolverine now you
can you can decapitate him and that'll
be as long as you keep his head
separated from his body then wolverine
will basically stay dead the problem is
how do you cut through the adamantium
bonding to a skeleton that's not easily
done you would need
special weapons in order to pull that
off the the big thing they realize
though is that while he can't
necessarily die
he can be frozen and so they literally
just kind of like
cut you know put him out there on ice
cut a hole in the ice and then
drop him in and that's when wolverine's
like look i mean this guy you're talking
about in the bathroom
i didn't kill that guy right i'm not the
reason why that guy's dead and then as
he starts sniffing around that's when he
starts to panic and he's like you guys
need to get me out of here right like
you guys need to let me out of here
because something's coming for you and
that's when a head just comes flying
across the air right
lands in front of these guys and then
they're impaled by basically a tentacle
and that's when we find out omega red is
the one who killed that guy now the
whole thing behind this is that omega
red was basically
put to lure wolverine out into the open
the question of
why is something that we'd actually find
out later instead what you end up having
here is just this kind of
giant coming together of all these
vampires showing up here on the scene
and that's kind of the crazy bit of a
revelation here the whole basis behind
this is that omega red was basically a
mold that the idea of these vampires
consuming wolverine's blood for the
purpose of trying to find a way to stay
in the sun
that was the whole point of dracula
that's what dracula wanted dracula
wanted the ability to walk around in the
daylight and wolverine's healing factor
seemed to grant the ability to do that
now
again under any normal circumstance this
would probably never work but because
krakowa is so focused on humanity and
because humanity's so focused on krakowa
it's allowed these vampires to kind of
lay these plans and sort of allow these
things to come to fruition and so that's
when you end up finding out that omega
red was basically planted by the vampire
nation that everything from the moment
when he
showed up inside of cocoa and said hey
like you know i'm i'm here because i'm
seeking amnesty
all the way to this moment was basically
designed for the purpose of
allowing uh allowing wolverine to be
drawn out so vampires could get a hold
of his blood
and so what you end up having is this
kind of dispersing it's a little bit of
an interesting plot thread
it doesn't seem like it's overly
important but basically vampires are
beefing up their numbers
quite readily that they're going through
and just biting all kinds of people and
in doing that
growing their numbers at a very fast
pace now the biggest question you
probably have to ask here is why isn't
blade responding to any of this why
don't we see
blade dealing with this well so that
question i don't really have an answer
you could say maybe he is dealing with
it but he's much like on the same path
as wolverine where he's kind of figuring
out
what's going on he just hasn't gotten as
far as wolverine has but basically these
two
unnamed i would call them like
lieutenants of uh of dracula is really
the best way to refer to them as are
just kind of
letting all these people loose around
the city of minneapolis in the hopes
that they will bite other people and
those individuals will become vampires
so you guys you guys see how it works
it's like a viral infection that if left
unmonitored or untreated
it'll grow at an exponential rate right
it'll just like literally one person
bites three people those three people
bite three other people right like three
people each right so one becomes three
becomes nine and it just starts going
like that in an exponential way just
growing
rapidly right everything blows up by a
factor of three and that's just being
conservative with numbers right what if
that one person
bites like nine other people before
they're caught right well then suddenly
the entire world's overrun with vampires
in them in a matter of like a few days
right like that's how fast
these things can take place now for
wolverine himself again
still kind of encased in this block of
ice there's a couple of young vampire
kids who realize he's there and they're
like i mean this is kind of interesting
i can't believe they just left him here
so they go to take him and then
basically wolverine breaks free but the
funny thing about this is that unlike a
lot of the other vampires that we see
they're not really looking to be
villains right they're not really
looking to go around
and consume human blood instead they
feed on animals now
i know this seems like a little bit of a
weird thing to throw in here like why in
the heck are we talking about wolverine
and vampires one of the things you
remember when it comes to like dawn of x
ten of swords
reign of x this is all building to
something right this is not necessarily
written by jonathan hickman it's written
by benjamin percy but the entire x-men
landscape is being monitored and
organized by jonathan hickman what this
means is that
this is all going to become important
later on because say for example this
giant war does break out between humans
and
and mutants then what if humans have
like vampires on their side and
different things like that it's this
just
literal gigantic multifaceted war it's
one of these things where by virtue of
the stories that they're telling and the
allies that wolverine's making here
they're stockpiling numbers and so
ultimately when the when the revelation
is kind of revealed to these at least
you know to wolverine on behalf of these
young kids that there is a desire by way
of this this kind of vampire nation to
expand their numbers then they kind of
present themselves with allies and say
look that's not really what we're
looking for that's not really what we
want we'll help you out as best we can
and so they literally help wolverine
topple a whole bunch of these different
vampires and kind of stem this this
immediate outbreak whether or not we see
another one
unfold only time will tell but it's one
of the things that they say that like
the fact that they've been able to
extract blood from wolverine
basically means they can use that blood
right they can go through
and they can kind of bond it to
themselves and allow it to sort of heal
them even if only temporarily because
they only have so much they can actually
use
and then in turn expand their numbers
during the daylight and the nighttime
hours
and then at that point once their
numbers are large enough then they'll be
a threat and they'll actually challenge
the mutant population
so in effect what this says is that a
war between the vampires and the mutants
are coming and that's crazy man because
those guys can't catch a break right
either you've got the children of the
vault who are basically
evolving humans in order to become like
these almost god-like beings that are
targeting the mutant population you've
got humanity who's targeting the mutant
population just like they always are
you got rogue governments who are doing
it you've even got alien forces out
there who were doing it
and now you've got vampires who are
doing it man like the x-men are just
screwed man i feel like it was the worst
idea of charles xavier ever
to form krakowa because they've done
nothing but make enemies but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace